the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to day seven
this is the seventh round of the 2022
fall chess classic and we have something
very exciting going on my name is
Jonathan schrupps and I'm happy to be
joined with Grand Master Miro and we're
going to be taking a look at this game
in Miro it's actually it's kind of a
tale of two different tournaments like
in one tournament we see a very very
close race and in the other we might see
somebody running with it potentially
today or tomorrow you know so it's a
little bit different uh right it's
absolutely different once again the
previous round had no draws whatsoever
in the B group yeah Alex Slenderman he
is inclined to run with the win right
absolutely so let's go ahead and get to
know the standings so that people can
kind of follow along with us but in
group a we actually have a tie for first
place we got Yu Yang Yi and Gregory
o'parin this is going to be kind of
interesting to see what is going on with
those two guys today and then we have
vidit Gujarati and Von duin sitting at
three and a half points just a half
Point behind the leaders Hans Neiman
Ilya nijnick and nijan amsov all have
three points they are still just a point
behind anything really could happen in
the next couple days here our macobion
has two and a half Nicholas theodoro has
two and Surya Ganguly has one and a half
Miro could you please let us know what's
going on in the B group it's a little
bit different yeah it's a little bit
different it's a lot different right we
have lindemon on the clear first with
one point distance from the second place
uh title the second is advani and
Christopher Ryu Dennis Scott Rich up to
his yesterday's win it was a very nice
game so he finds himself on the fourth
position
gigolicanther Brendan Jacobson on 50
percent three out of six Christian
well improves his result a little bit
he's tied with tigran harunyan Chandra
on Two And poorerman mikhailan still has
only half a point that is correct and
let's get to know our tournament with
the tournament format this is a
tournament that features two 10 player
round happens you saw that there's an a
group and there's a b group the time
control for today's event is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves then you get 30
minutes for the rest of the game and all
throughout there is a 30 second anchor
in Chris Miro could you please let us
know the schedule for the last couple
days uh yes so last couple of days
today's day today's round as you could
see already has started tomorrow no
changes one PM is the start of the round
and well after three hours it's thought
of our show and on the last day the
round will start a couple of hours
earlier because in case of a tie the
playoff match will happen the same day 5
PM
absolutely and like always we are here
live on Twitch on YouTube we are reading
all of your comments we've got YouTube
asking us hey what is that building that
we were looking at in the intro to the
show you were able to see the Chase Park
Plaza and our cameraman had walked all
the way through the building uh to give
you kind of an idea of where these
players are playing today and if you do
want to catch up with us on social media
use the hashtag fall chess classic or
watch all of the games live on
uschesschamps.com and like always I just
want to impress on everybody that all of
the money that we are raising whether
you're watching ads on YouTube whether
you're giving bits donations uh
subscriptions on Twitch it all goes to
an amazing cause it raises for every 75
dollars that we get we're able to
sponsor one child for an entire semester
that otherwise might not be able to have
a chess program in their school so it's
a really cool thing where a kid that
won't be getting it actually might be
able to get chess which is an awesome
thing to do but uh with all that out of
the way we are now going to jump in and
check out our pairings today for the a
group in the a group we have Aaron
Jacobian going up against Gregory
o'parin Yu Yang Yi is going up against
Nicholas list theodoro Von Nguyen is
going up against Surya Ganguly nijan
absov versus ilyaneshnik and our game of
the day is Hans Neiman vs vidit Gujarati
Hans of course on six out of six perfect
draws uh vidit has three and a half so
this is something that will have our
attention uh maybe one of these guys is
able to catch up with you yangi on this
leaderboard here
um all right and they play quite an
unorthodox position which actually
started as something really quiet but
now for perhaps for the first time in
this tournament I can really say that
well hans's position is unbalanced he
wants to lift every single person it's
like yeah I can't really moved all of
them yeah I can't really say okay
deviliation is such optically I would
perhaps prefer black but you know for
the first time so remember all those
have King safety or is it anything else
yeah like like the strange the strange
term over extension right because when
you push them too hard and kind of don't
have the pieces to back this squares up
right so light Square Bishop would be
perfect yes on G2 yeah but since the
bishop won't have to Black was his last
move Bishop F3 uh while perhaps asking
white to move the pawn even further so
then all the light squares all the these
huge long diagonal will be open and in
this cases I believe I mean it's not
that important if white say wins the B7
Pawn or so on it's more about the king
safety so that's yeah and how did this
all happen I mean somehow what compelled
hands to move every single part uh right
it actually started in a very say very
civilized way and into Indian E3 Bishop
D3 Knight F3 and that's uh that's
awesome it's very normal yeah Knight G2
perhaps is somewhat more popular
nowadays but Knight F3 is of course this
fundamental line that yeah people
started to play 1930s and yeah continue
to play till that day yeah
so cd5 apart from cd5 you can Castle you
can I guess go a tree pretty much any
moment which forces the exchange on C3
but yeah cd585 immediately D takes C5 so
this way uh black plays with an isolated
Pawn like B to D7 and Hans yeah just
just goes Bishop D2 which seems to be
like an awkward development of this
bishop on D2 but yeah an isolated Pawn
still going to B3 attacks the bishop
castles and this is the moment where
black I believe can but I don't know if
he should play D4 because you kind of
even all destruction why it takes 120s
black takes with the queen yeah okay we
could quickly run through this one uh so
Knight takes Knight takes Pawn takes
Queen takes and Bishop E3 and I guess
black might have some slight
difficulties like Bishop E3 Bishop F3
later on says and maybe some slight
inconveniences for black uh anyway A6
still like I'm checking the database
they run like big names player plate
this position
A4 and yeah A4 perhaps is the first kind
of slightly independent move there were
games but not only a very high level
okay so A4 simply stops B5 yeah Knight
to C5 Queen A2 Bishop E6 and this is
perhaps not uh the best option for Black
Knight D4 Bishop D6 Rook F2 D1 Queen E7
and Bishop to E1 white Consolidated the
isolated Pawn is still somewhat weak uh
Bishop F3 potential move right if needed
white can trade on E6
and then Hans goes with F3 which is like
perhaps a logical move in order to
restrict those night jumps but also you
create yourself a Target on a tree right
and this is where it started so like
when Bishop D7 Bishop F2 Queen E5 like
tread of the thread of the threat right
the cell black is just slowly provoking
him to move every Pawn G3 Queen to H5
and Hans never was was kind of never
planning to stop so B4 and F4 and
everything goes forward Knight to G4 and
here machine was suggesting to take on
G4 with the bishop which is like an
awkward move to make you just weaken all
the lights
on the other hand he went H4 which
optically it looks even worse so Bishop
takes Knight takes D5 Knight to D4 Rook
to D4 Bishop to C5 Rook D2 Bishop E6
Rook a to D1 and maybe that's the moment
where or rather that position Hans was
spinning some hopes with because Knight
F6 is a threat and feels like it's it's
somewhat awkward for black but black
found Rook E8 sidestep in the all the
tricks and perhaps indirectly putting
some pressure on the E3 Pawn Hans ended
up yeah like when Queen B1 Queen to H6
ended up capturing
uh the Knight Rook C1 and Bishop f8 all
right and here we are E4 Bishop F3 and
while we were looking at all that rookie
one and queen E6 were played uh Queen to
H3
bringing it on these light squares Hans
moves yet another pun he just keeps
pushing and this time okay F5 F5
[Music]
please need to find it not easy to find
the square for this queen unless it's an
a queen to E5 okay yeah and I'm somewhat
embarrassed because I I wasn't sure
where the queen goes after Bishop D4
yeah it's going to capture the pawn yeah
okay okay with this out of the way yeah
we can see some potential threats even
like tactics like Bishop Bishop C5 might
work at some point yeah
all right well this yeah already looks
like Hans may be under a little bit of
pressure here we'll have to see what
happens in this game uh but before that
let's jump into the B group and let's
see what's going on with our B group
standings
I'll hear the pairings for the big group
rather are Dennis cadrich going up
against Christian Carrillo Armin
michalian going up against Brandon
Jacobson Garrett Goulding cantar going
up against Christopher you akshat
Chandra versus tigran hartunyan and Alex
Slenderman our tournament Leader by a
full point is going up against Rana
sadwani and this is also a big one
because ronak is in second place with
four points so a lot of stuff could
happen here but obviously Linderman is
off to a really hot start and if he is a
good position or somehow like gets a win
today or something he could start to
just run away with this even with a day
or two left to go what is going on in
this game
um all right so first things first
Lenderman is up a pawn so he has won a
born somewhere around E4 because you go
through the game it's always nice at
some point yeah but somehow somehow this
bishop came to life uh it's it was
it was this one one of those
um Carlsbad structure positions where a
black very often ends up with the bishop
187 okay we probably should just go
through the game so so it'll be a little
bit more clear what did this one start
yeah but it looked what I'm trying to
say that at some point or it wasn't
material up but it looked very promising
sure now yeah it's I want to say just
the pawn okay sure there is a pawn but
still you need to convert it and at
least all the black pieces kind of came
to life right so uh everything on the
open files open diagonals so black
perhaps is not that unhappy with this
scenario it did look worse at some point
okay so it was another Queen's Gambit we
had quite a quite a few of those Knight
to C3 Knight B to D7 and yeah and white
decided to go for Carlsbad variation
here kind of one move later so C takes e
takes that makes it so that white has
the Knight one F3 which is considered by
some not the best setup in cars but yeah
a lot of people prefer yeah develop the
bishop go E3 Bishop D3 and Knight G2
yeah if if the Knight is still in G1 but
at the same time black already committed
to Knight d7s well he doesn't have those
lines with an early Bishop F5 all right
all right Queen to C2 C6 Bishop F4 not
to G5 perhaps doesn't make that much
sense Knight H5 so he doesn't really uh
doesn't really want uh White to keep the
bishop on this on this diagonal and he
go 2015 immediately otherwise white
would have played H3 and always would
have Bishop yeah
so therefore yeah not H5 Bishop G5 just
trades the Bishops E3 A5 and wait a
second after E3 you have a bunch a bunch
of high profile games like Hikaru played
against a Rooney and rajab of morosevic
the aquan against Bono Mario back in
2011 so that's a kind of a
well-established one and they were still
debating this one huh yeah yeah and then
A5 all of a sudden on move 10 it's
almost like a novelty at least no games
in the database I'm using A5 Bishop B2
and the point yeah of course you'd
prefer Bishop D3 but then black has
Knight to F4 right the E Pawn is pinned
with the queen so that's why Bishop to
E2 somewhat motor is development castles
Knight back to F6 yeah Castle castles
back to F6 Knight to D2 Rook E8 Bishop
D3 with a loss of attempt simple but so
be it
rookie one
and this is where the bishop starts
um okay yeah it's journey to G6 yeah it
had a lot of space so I guess this is
how we got yeah I mean he wants yeah
that's a very healthy idea to go to G6
and trade the bishop but
uh F4 is uh very principled and also
also very very strong myth so F4 uh
since Knight E4 is not possible Right
black does not have control over E4
white threatens to trap the bishop
perhaps or at least he's always ready to
meet Bishop G6 with F5 so H7 H6 happen
now
perhaps G4 would have been nah now G4
was played I'm just I'm just wondering
trying to make F5 work or something yeah
five maybe start with a five maybe and
then you know then G4 on the next move
but perhaps it's not it's kind of easier
said than done right green D6 or
something or even like make a move and
if G4 just take it twice also might be
not that obvious uh what the evaluation
is why you need to make sure work has
some threads 93 Knight to G5 yeah
fair enough so lend the month just cares
with seizing more space G4 Bishop G6 F5
everything with the tempo and yeah and
that's the bishop which in our position
is currently we know it's going to get
out somehow yeah so now it's interesting
we saw in the Huns game Hans had moved
all the Pawns in front of the king but
it looked like in that game he's kind of
getting attacked this one is much
different it looks like white moved them
all but it's kind of restricting all
that black Splash here yeah that's the
thing I mean this F5 Pawn does a lot of
job right it prevents the knight from
jumping to G6 or E6 it also blocks the
bishop on H7 and white has enough pieces
to back those pawns up right Queen G3
yeah that that's one pathetic Bishop I
have to say like the bishop G8 and then
yeah black uh perhaps had not a lot to
do but to jump to you for Knight D2 and
then if you attempt to defend it with
Knight F6 I guess G5 comes quickly so
therefore F6 was played Knight to B6
Knight to D5 okay uh that's what
happened
here Lenderman captured Bishop takes A3
Rook 88 and King H2 interesting all
right
so white is up upon here yeah but once
again it's not that easy right I mean so
the raw weaknesses on light squares if
you I don't know what black does let's
pass for now okay if you go E4 then yeah
okay he drops the bishop back to F7 and
then always has the threat of B6 so kind
of both pawns are a little bit hanging
here it might be you know E4 E5 might be
just the way to win immediately right as
well yeah like if you say E5 works and
then you're just crashing but it has to
be done with with caution that that's
what I mean right so I won't be
surprised if White's position is like
close to winning but got some
contemplation all right so later in will
need to have a lot of care here he is a
fun up for the moment so we'll see what
happens there we have had our first
result of the game in the ilionic game
so it might be worth taking a look at
this game in its totality
just made the draw in the alarming
Sicilians all right
yeah let's see if it was just you know
Rich players will be at three and a half
points now a region of 30 uh agree a
draw or was it a real fight all right
let's see Knight F3 Knight A3 wow good
old Good Old Knight A3 line yeah yeah
point being like pretty much whatever
you do except for what blackhead did in
the game next move is going to be not B5
threatening F4 so A6 then it allows
white to go Knight seats so we threaten
another Fork yep 93 Queen C6 Bishop B2
so I brought the Knight to E3 I don't
know for good or for bad and C4 right
and now he travels D5 and C takes Knight
takes Queen to C7 computer at some point
was very happy with how it looked for
black
3b6 Bishop F3 Bishop B7 yeah and this is
this is always the case with those uh
structures and I had plenty of those
from you can get from E4 from French
defenses also sometimes something
similar happens from the closed openings
uh
like the structure itself suggests that
white has to play on the queen side like
you have the majority and so on right
but at the same time you've developed
this stupid Bishop on B2 so it points at
the K points at the key and then you
don't know where to go I mean so I would
argue that actually say having the
bishop only three and the Knight on C3
would be better for white like they're
kind of more prepared for the for the
queen side kind of queen Side Advance
right interesting and here it's kind of
why this finds himself sort of in the
middle he doesn't know where where to go
next so Rook B8 Bishop B7 of course it's
somewhat kind of over
or simplifying things yeah Knight F3
Rook d8 95 and black is just on time to
trade all the Rooks go back to D7 and
yeah yeah okay all right we can see how
things started to get traded off Knight
to E8 and yeah once again optically it
looks like white is getting somewhere
but Bishop F6 or sometimes just F6
Bishop C5 and black gets all the Tempe
back
and just repeat it we got it we figured
it out don't worry about it let's just
repeat those yeah guys are guys are very
very solid that's pretty professional
way to end the game all right and Yeah
we actually do have a request from the
chats they want to see one of our
tournament leaders Oparin coming up
that's the one that's the one you ask
and we deliver oh look at this okay this
looks fun
so that's move 26 that it is um like
really strange looking yeah this is cool
and if anything I would predict like
pragos in defense of some sort so black
went Bishop before went C5 dc5 captured
on C3 okay the only problem with this
theory that the C7 Pawn is still there
so how do you play C5 with the C7 phone
yeah okay how do we get here it was it
was the scotch in fact it was the score
okay we've seen a couple of days I'm
talking yeah about uh this question
yeah not not the single mold Scotch but
the other scotch it's Knight to F6 uh
trades E5 and this one is it's really
confusing Queen E7 Queenie 2 Knight D5
remember we had H4 in one of the games
like in early age four here another
C4 that's another normal yeah C4 was the
the main line for a very long time like
Gary was playing C4 now here it's Knight
D2 okay Knight D2 always been somewhat
mysterious to me because uh it's not
clear what white tries to you know to
achieve playing these moves or Rook to
B8
as far as I remember one of the replies
here we have like nepo cardiac in West
we saw video and so on and so on so Ray
Robson has played with white knight to
F4 Queen E3 Knight to G6 okay so so far
the benefit of Knight D2 is that black
has his Knight on G6 and not on B6
arguably Knight on G6 is much better
placed okay so we'll see what happens
yeah that's not clear why would you
anyway F4 Queen to C5 and this is like
the weapon a weird part starts okay
because yeah like Bishop E7 Queen's on
C5 for whatever reason Knight B3 and
then it skipped keeps kind of being
chased away Black Goes D5 no yes all
right takes on D6 Queen D6 castles long
Castle short
F5 Queen E5 so he is all about those
Intimates yeah it's really funny you
attack my queen how many Queen moves
says black yes
so we had wait a sec we had not so many
so Queen E7 and then later on it was uh
Queen to C5 it's two and queen two
before it's three and to D6 it's four
and it's five and after Bishop D3 queens
were traded ah no Bishop six yeah
yeah and that's perhaps the one that
white actually missed originally because
after Bishop six it is very annoying B2
is yeah it's a huge threat trading only
five allows almost means like losing
your Pawn because the Knight attacks
both the bishop in the pawn and also F5
Pawns
so he had no choice but to go Bishop C3
after which white uh black trades
compressy trees this is a nice little
series for black yeah that's an
interesting moment because white could
have tried to take on G6 and say Bishop
has to go and take on I believe F7 not
H7 staking on H7 means this Pawn is
going to be lost sooner like the G6 and
takes yeah but that would that would
mean playing versus a pair of Bishops he
decided not to he captured back on C3
Knight to E5 C5
Bishop A6 Knight D4 Bishop C4 traded on
C6 Bishop A2 rook h2e1 and H5 so black
arguably has a better structure even the
past Pawn on the a file but white has
control and we'll both make it in there
first this is yeah this is crazy okay
would you say that anyone actually has
an advantage here or is this most likely
a draw once again I mean
the you know the
the habit of um say analyzing this stuff
with the computer suggests that yeah I
mean everything the previous experience
everything is everything's a draw you
just have to be yeah like whenever you
see some exciting structure that means
that they'll be right there it's a rook
end game
right I mean for one of the sides yeah
so white in order to have like something
serious
he has to press over the seventh rank
but the bishop on A2 actually guards of
seven so you could try to go after C7
Pawn but then perhaps black will have
some sort of contemplate uh hence he
plays H5 so now no back ranked threads
of any sort and maybe start will start
like lifting Rooks to like beat three
and B8 it's actually not that many
squares on this B file now I realize
yeah because black wouldn't mind let's
say having
The Rook on B2 and the other one on B8
right and all of a sudden it looks looks
tremendous for black but it's not that
easy to achieve okay we'll see all right
so this is one of our tournament leaders
Gregory o'parin so we'll definitely come
back and keep an eye on this one but uh
when we left the Hans Neiman game Hans
was just in a little bit of trouble we
weren't sure what was going to happen he
moved all the Pawns in front of his King
we weren't sure what's going on maybe we
can take another look at that game and
see if there's been any progress
okay okay the bin moves uh not sure if
progressed right so what I'm what I can
see is that it is quite low on time
eight minutes but that's yeah that
smells 36 so that's not uh not something
too terrible
um oops and now sorry so F5 Queen E5
yeah so we saw up to here in Knight B6
Bishop C5 was it was it overworked
yeah is this an issue yeah like how do
you guard how do you guard G3
he
I presume capturing this guy is not a
serious option
yeah because check on
first of all this one it looks strong
enough about it looks strong enough yeah
it looks like a queen takes G3 because
if this is a winner yeah I suspect that
one uh black just wins like this like a
check here
uh check here King E3 now black has to
be a little bit accurate I mean Rook it
takes E4 Queen takes E4 and Black's own
Queen is under attack but like playing
some move here
I mean what are we talking about yeah so
that seems to be very dangerous seems to
be very dangerous and the only way to
guard this Pawn is actually to play a
move was the king like King H2O or King
F1 and say King H2 which seems like what
you would want to be able to do yeah
that looks like it might be losing
materials oh
to play it simple I mean so yeah the
king is still in some danger White
Knight is bit too far away like Knight
D7 Rook D7 just loses
this is I guess even stronger than like
just taking the bishop and yeah you
could take the bishop yeah I could take
the Bishops are falling off but but then
yeah but then Rook takes right and then
when we trade everything I ate these
things so that's one yeah okay it's
funny enough because I say queen F5 I'm
trying to take this one with a check if
you trade only yeah even though white is
a knight ABS even though the white is a
night up Knight can't really return back
so even this one looks like okay but
yeah marginally playable sure but black
can obviously do better yeah black
probably will find a way to do better
King H2 is on the board with it is
thinking okay
interesting all right so we'll get to
see what that it actually plays here
yeah he could try could he know but
before still not
not an option but there is a feeling
something something's terribly wrong
with what uh hang on a second if you
want to win a pawn why don't we just
take on B6
say something takes Bishop takes right
and we take E4
and it's not necessarily about the pawn
because say the B Pawn white can play A5
the pawns blocked it's never never gonna
move but it's more about once again
opening the diagonal and the King safety
and F5 Pawn if anything yeah just this
danger of opening up your king so much
yeah so that's that he might regret
pushing those F and H pawns then hmm
I think you have been given some credit
at least by a chat they're saying your
Rook d8 move may actually be the best we
can come back and also take a look at
that I may have tricked you out of
analyzing the best move
I'm assuming they're talking about this
position they must be saying yeah I just
need to go back and forth yeah Bishop
but he already captured yeah
maybe this was also very once again like
like from from experience you have
facing all these all the guys yeah in
the action and then this fell out on A8
does does nothing so yeah so Rook d8 is
at least it's a move to consider right I
mean once again if I'd be playing the
game I cannot claim that yeah I'd play
Rook V8 instantaneously so that's one of
the candidates one of the strong
candidate moves absolutely but instead
he took the Knight yeah a video decided
for simple chess just captured captured
on B6 uh he can take E4 if for whatever
reason he's not happy with he can play
Rook C8 maybe to while planning to say
lift the rook and both of those options
look very good for blank how much
trouble would you say Hans is in here
[Music]
um
really depends if E4 is up for grabs
because if you just take a four and go
away with it it might be like a couple
of Pawns deficit so like losing yeah
like losing oh my gosh this could be
huge once I said all draws so far
and this could potentially be his first
loss yeah well anyway very unpleasant
position for sure all right so we're
definitely coming back to this one we'll
see what's going on uh is there any
other games that we haven't checked out
yet then maybe have your interest maybe
the the Christopher you game that's
another important one for the standings
absolutely so back to the B tournament
and let's check so we agreed on
Lenderman having a very promising
position right against
uhwani that means if he wins he'll be
two points clear of round knock with two
rounds to go and the closest rival with
will be Christmas for you so this is
very important Christopher you needs to
have a good day today yeah but he
doesn't have it he doesn't have it that
that's what that's move 38 or yeah moves
38 and one of the reasons why this game
is still in progress is that it's just
white is very low on time
like one minute 40 seconds other than
that it's an extra exchange for not much
of a compensation and what move are they
on now
because they get bonus time at move 40.
move 38 and this is okay move 30. so a
couple of months
[Music]
all right this one looks interesting how
did we get here it was it was something
really strange in the opening so once
again it's uh the ninja but this time
Queen C2 and that's one of the lines
that Hikaru at some point was playing a
lot sure castles and then E4 and E4 yeah
this is a sharp line it's a very sharp
line or rather used to be the sharp line
and then they figured out that D5 and a
lot of Sharps theoretical moves and you
agree a draw because everything
everything it's all worked out yeah yeah
everything's work out
but every now and again someone comes up
with like a little idea you can't really
refute the line but sure like maybe I
mean if you did not repeat everything
with black you come to the game you see
this position and you understand okay
Define now I will have to figure out
around around middle 25 white will have
a few tries and I have no clue which one
he'll he picks for this game yeah and
some people just play D5 yeah some
people just play D6 all right yeah and
you do have games here like Magnus had
this position with white there was a
Fabiano game with black against Muhammad
yarov said it's not it's not absolutely
same idea yeah white goes with E5 Knight
to D7 e takes he takes Knight F3
Knight to C6 Bishop D3 targeting disks
they stood and then yeah in this
position we have only one game in the
database it's valierejo against Abdus
back when Vallejo was a huge ELO
favorite I'm assuming what else would
you even think about
yeah certainly not yeah H6 was played
certainly not the move that was played
in our game he let what did he do E5 so
this Pawn he's hanging with the check
wow you probably don't take immediately
because then D4 is hanging and G6 is
attract right and he didn't do this
instead he went with D5 what could be
okay what could be easier than the D5 D5
Bishop to G5 first okay and now I reckon
F6 white would take and then two minutes
extra kind of too many light Square
weaknesses also there might be some
Knight H4 with Knight G6 nasty threads
yeah this is all very nice not rushing
to take the H Pawn but coming up with a
few improving moves yes it's all about
you see I mean intermediate move is I
believe underrated the importance it's
like the biggest takeaway of this
tournament is find all those
intermediate moves yeah
now the pawn is captured Queen E4 and
now white oh boy actually does something
very straightforward go to each foreign
Checkmate so black was forced to go
Knight F6 Bishop takes on days and this
looks this looks like a disaster for
black so I'm actually surprised that at
some point his position looked almost
normal what's kind of funny about this
structure he had it like yesterday right
in the Sicilian black had this position
but the king got all the way to E7 where
it was totally safe he doesn't look as
safe on age eight right well he did
escape from the corner but yeah at the
coast okay Queen H4 King G7 has to be
played Bishop to E4 once again a threat
of Checkmate in one Rook h8 Queen
if you can get those Queens off you
won't get checkmated immediately yep so
C5 Bishop D5
finally white trades all right and girls
age three all right so now I presume
Bishop F3 it is just Bishop F3 and Rook
to D7 maybe after Rook C8 you actually
throw in C6 so that could be yeah black
can't really take with with the Rook has
to capture with the Knight and Rook to
D7 Bishop to D5 back
I didn't know how bad does it look
uh instead Bishop F5 was played but this
allows white to continue pushing this
pawns H4 and C4 ended like everything
goes up the board
H6 G5 really breaking through absolutely
E4 Knight to D2 Rook takes 94 Rook D5
well got engaged into some tactical
tricks sure Rook takes a check King D2
all right all the knights are hanging
and yeah and if it turns out if you are
planning to take with the bishop and
it's kind of a you know double attack H7
wins and maybe many things win perhaps
like
up to the point that you can actually
maybe you could actually take and please
take one of these Rooks H7 H7 is gonna
yeah I mean this is ironic because it's
it's also a Checkmate very nice uh right
so he ended up capturing the Knight with
the Rook white captains on A5 check King
E3 check okay some checks okay uh but as
soon as they've yeah they've just
reached me 40. captures King G8 Rook A7
Bishop E4 okay
all right so the king will be kind of
say fish on H7 for some time you had a
little hesitation there I mean there's
black just in too much trouble here do
you think no I think he he's just lost
that's the point I'm just the station
was like how do we win as white like in
the shortest way yeah but you probably
don't need like look for the shortest
way to just give a check
I guess give a check if King H7 go to G7
just pick the opponent we have to be a
little careful taking that pawn bishop
D5 yeah fair enough so but maybe maybe
yeah maybe I changed my mind maybe maybe
I just go back if you can get them stuck
on the H file maybe bad things will
happen yeah Rook H4 top news for
Christopher Christopher one of the the
people that could potentially catch up
to Alex Slenderman if he's losing and
Alex's I mean at least drawing maybe
winning
um you know it's Slenderman he's gonna
be running away with the B section yep
wow all right so we'll come back and see
if Christopher somehow can hold on to
this one but uh I think also we have
some big news in the chorilla game that
one might be worth taking a game
against Dennis black with cartridge and
Country Chase performance in this
tournament was quite quite impressive
yeah
in a brilliant fashion or loses yeah
disastrously so let's work for the
spectators yeah that's exactly what you
can hope for let's find out what uh
Christian's tournament started a little
slow but it's been getting better and
just kind of taking a quick look I don't
know this might be really good for him
yeah it's a last few moves I mean
probably like like since we are getting
to time troubles there might be not
enough time to look at every game right
from the start but because the Dynamics
in last few moves well yeah why it's up
upon what black has better King for the
end game Run the D5 pawns week and uh
the C Pawn the past C Pawn which will
materialize on the board will be quite
quite unpleasant for blood for white to
handle
and yeah and that that's a little bit
sad for white he has to play before in
order to have some Bishop C5 ideas but
that means that C4 Pawn is he's here to
stay yeah Rook to F4
Rook to F4
the yep not clear what would you what
would you actually do
this is well maybe try for a say for a
rookan game just return the pawn goes
like King F3
but still right the D5 is weak yeah yeah
I think we like Christian senses here
yeah I think like Christian chances it
was 33 just to keep you and just for a
laugh if we play H3 what would uh yeah
this might be a good idea here I guess
he just did you begin pushing
immediately Target's this guy
yeah there is a check I understand but
then once again
everything lines not very nicely
yeah Rook behind the passport Bishop B2
or F4 and we win material right so
that's why you're kind of eager to maybe
give up on back just yeah this one so
white actually went with Bishop takes A7
instead of H3 and I keep wondering if
black has to take the pawn or maybe
still can go this is what a budget yeah
so this is a big sacrifice right because
he's winning or is that yeah
and point being like I'm planning still
to capture this one with a check but I
want the C4 Square for The Rook when The
Rook is attacked right and on Bishop a
uh ah Bishop B8 pardon me that that
that's a something to it okay to watch
out for yeah good point I didn't know if
you had a brilliant you were just
snacking a bishop going nuts just
promoting it absolutely I I went like
crazy okay so then check perhaps but
then it's yeah then it's not that
straightforward check
not sure where the King goes like H3 not
pleasant if three allows me one more
maybe this one more check is nothing so
what I mean
black probably has to end up yeah has to
end up with The Rook on G8 and then
perhaps yeah then perhaps chances of
suddenly I can give you four even yeah
anybody's game then huh we went from
thinking Christian has a great position
to I don't know maybe godric is going to
figure something out so this one's a
little wild it's very unbalanced and
we'll see we'll let the players figure
it out and we'll get back to you uh with
some updated speaking of updates I think
there's been something happening
all right and wait so when we left it
Hans was in a little bit of trouble we
were kind of getting worried for him
maybe he first Lost first question where
are the Queens Bishop E4 Rook D E2
and that's something that perhaps we
just overlooked when went for capturing
yeah because it looks like black was
just winning a pond but maybe sneakily
traded everything off technically he is
up a pawn right but that's the same Pawn
that we kept talking B7 which doesn't
really matter if white just gives a uh
five and
yeah all of a sudden this looks way more
holdable than when we have absolutely
maybe is he I don't know wondering if
he's gotten out of all the trouble
absolutely I mean perhaps you know like
like really really needs to like come up
with a couple of good moves to at least
keep theoretical chances because I
believe like if you allow white the next
move is going to be H5 specifically to
kind of because what I want is to build
H5 G4 structure kind of thing so any
time black starts pushing the pawns I'm
just trading everything it's the more
black won't be able to make it yeah the
more we trade the less we blunder that
that's how I was taught yeah and the
plan on the green side is just to go A5
and let it be
all right yeah very good chance it looks
like Hans has gotten out of any if he
wasn't any trouble it looks like he's
not anymore as far as
white you could even trade Rooks maybe
like yeah
we are ready to trade the Rooks yeah
yeah all right so that's seventh draw
coming up all right so maybe in this one
though maybe he's kind of a little bit
more fortunate to get him some of them
have been yeah well it's a little bit
different that's like almost winning
so we'll come back here if there's
anything that uh changes but maybe
there's some other games let's just
quickly do a run through so this is one
win against the Surya Ganguly
he waits Arbor porn but opposite colored
Bishops once again looks like almost a
fortress or maybe maybe strangely enough
oddly enough uh the winning chance for
white would be to actually trade the
Rooks like get the king to G6 and then
somewhere you trade the words and black
might have difficulties defending
defending the GC and this one is going
to be huge because uh Von Nguyen is only
a half Point behind the leaders so this
actually yeah for the standings is not
moving that quickly right a lot more
draws it's a lot more draw heavy than
the B section so every single extra half
point that you get really goes a long
way in this one absolutely then uh whoa
you Yang Yi is actually under attack
against him all right with four points
uh yes have we seen no no we hadn't
checked this one yeah this one so we'll
definitely check out yeah yeah from the
very start so that was
which leads to more of like neither fish
structures yeah and that was Battle
tested in the world championship yeah in
the world championship match yes and
Magnus has played it in classical games
and also I think he won one of the one
of the playoff rapid games with this one
okay
so yeah A5 and that's something
that something not seen very often I
guess I'm just trying to understand when
they've deviated from Carolina constant
uh Bishop D2 Bishop D2 is something new
yes Fabi was playing perhaps Bishop E2
Bishop D2 for whatever reason is like a
clever clever move A6 C4 Bishop E2
all right
but still it's very neither fish once
again imagine the night of a white
somewhere went Knight D5 black captured
white took with the epon and then white
tries to push these guys as much as
possible black has does his thing on the
king's side do you have any preference
for either side and these kinds of
structures or anything I think it's
probably up to personal preference yeah
so I always felt like black has high
rate successes just because you're
attacking it is more like Adela as a
Checkmate but same logic with you know
with the old lines of King's Indian when
everything's blocked and you push these
c a b pawns and black pushes the fgh
pawns because the you know the object of
your attack is a little bit more
viable so to speak right I wanted to say
material in fact it's yeah it's likely
the opponent might make a mistake if you
put him under some pressure you can't
make a mistake at least one extra
opponent you make a mistake
yeah yeah
so right Bishop to d8 and in this weird
way he at the same time keeps the Knight
on E5 protected by a b so he doesn't
want to take with the Deep Pawn
obviously and yeah and also the bishop
was attacking the A5 pawn queen to D4
Bishop back to F6 this way
black perhaps wins the temple C5 G5 this
is where it starts like sides pushing uh
the pawns at each other
F4 Bishop F5 yeah once again we split
the board in half Queen side we look at
the queen side what's overwhelmingly
winning and the same for the inside and
black like black saying let's not look
at the king size huge attack yeah the
black hair is a huge attack so F7 uh D7
sorry F3 yeah Bishop takes Rook takes
Rook to B7 Queen H6 well it might be
that Theodore just plays a brilliant
game of chess Rook to BC I'd be so
scared and he's also like almost asking
for things
so irritating right no the answer is no
and F6 Pawn so strong so it takes on F6
G takes Pawn takes Bishop F three and
queen to H4 So the plan as far as I get
it is to play Rook H6 rookie one yeah
but the king if anything can try can
potentially try to run away
we'll see rookie one that's the yeah
that's the position
out of trouble here it's it's very close
it feels like it's kind of on the edge
yeah that's a it's a crazy game I mean
it can be anybody's game because if
white saves the king he's still like two
pawns up even if he loses H2 he's one
Pawn up and black skin is also not very
safe
uh yeah so it is like yeah so cool one
of those positions when you you really
required to calculate on every single
move and not so much time left
yeah both players running a little bit
low on time Yu Yang Yi tournament leader
and kind of a very tricky interesting
position like I'm not saying tricky in
the like you're gonna lose weight it's
just it's a very complicated position
all right so he he gave a check in G7
and might as well consider like going
voluntarily to F1 yeah all the way
home Castle position right but very
exciting stuff very exciting we'll
definitely have to come back to this one
this one is very important for the
tournament yeah and I remember people
who are requesting your boring's game so
here it is but it's uh okay we got some
changes it's got thing
kind of sort of beat us out and I guess
if anyone it's it's white who's who's
pushing so why it's currently to move
can similarly just take the H5 Pawn
be up upon I mean uh yeah sure what's
just upon Rook C5 King to D2 let's say
or
yeah there is no discovered
so we've had a lot of these positions
but it's always been with opposite
colored Bishops here we see it's two
light squared Bishops does that give
anybody better chances of winning uh
right I believe white is a better is
like
trying to win this and the the red side
did
dominant Factor would be if he's able to
consolidate so give give white couple of
moves he plays Bishop F3 then okay
yeah like everything's solid he is up
Pawn but yeah but maybe black has a
bishop B4 you know he doesn't today is
the day I'm blundering the Bishops right
but also this Bishops hanging at the end
yeah exactly so whatever yeah exactly as
I said I mean white wouldn't mind
stabilizing but but he's nowhere near to
he's nowhere near to so it's still even
though it's the end game with just a
couple pieces left they just you know
okay so things could still happen here
being a bone down speaks for itself
exactly Richard or rather YouTube chat
has it yeah
if we could actually just park back to
the Hans game I've heard in chat too
they said your move that Rook a to d8 I
believe was on move 38 or so
um instead of Bishop maybe one yeah yeah
minus 2.3 yeah he actually missed it
okay and why
I guess you popped the computer open we
can just spoil what the computer was
said because we didn't get here group
fakes Rook takes and yeah apparently if
this happens white has difficulties kind
of defending the king and at the same
time the knights always like Knights
hanging in the air cannot return to the
game so give me a couple more stockfish
moves here here it's minus nine the best
move is Queen Queen here yeah just
defend the second ring and
by the way it's like yeah H6 is good
something else is good but the actual
strongest move is not really the first
move you to suggest is the human so you
attack the detail that's really good
yeah
and why do A5 because you also keep an
eye on those stupid horses the Queens
girls and then yeah then take the horse
all right let's see for me I'm not done
yet
it's not necessarily that white has to
go this route he has some Knight C4 he's
still fighting but black was like minus
two you're just a huge chance but what
really happened in the game would you
have any updates uh yeah Rook to D5
Bishop E4 enhancement for this he did
actually switch the Rooks to be
perfectly honest I'm not a big fan of
because it gives another pawn it gives
uh black another possible you're really
saying you're gonna hold this one look
uh so first of all B5 is something to
consider
so a trade here sure and you need to
guard a five dude right yeah I got G4 no
problem and then H5 happens
so now capturing
at least you can move your king up as
well it's like two yeah two you know two
two past pawns and that's exactly what
black needs takes takes then black runs
forward yeah I better use my Bishop yep
it runs forward
and I wasn't sure if it's a draw because
this one is constantly targeted
yeah I mean if you can run all the way
yeah white of course has this idea we've
gone to play with uh so what I'm saying
It's Tricky okay so you better have
figured all this out yeah and I'm not
sure he did I'm not sure he did and
moreover here okay
yeah it turns out that you're not forced
to take you can actually force a white
to take on H5 like like going here
and yeah computer is not sure I mean now
I'm actually sure do you I do use an
engine and and still compute is not sure
what it is like Bishop here some some
ideas with Bishop D1 maybe so it's not
yet so if stockfish can't figure it out
then I guess we don't yeah can't really
say for certain but no yeah it's crazy
though to go into this unless you're
very certain because there's also one
more idea yeah it is to take over here
yeah A5 I presume white wants to stop it
but yeah then in some position I mean
first you of course
you'll even go B5 takes and then have
the bishop here let's say stopping and
then the A5 Pawn is going to move so
even this might be a chance okay of
course not B5 immediately but right what
I'm saying yeah
still keep chances but maybe now maybe
Hans knows for sure
once again I'd be I'd be scared to go
for this indeed and
what's even kind of what I find
remarkable there it was move 41 when he
played Rook B8 so he had taken full time
oh so maybe he didn't think about I mean
he must think he can hold them maybe but
he still has like 56 minutes I mean
because maybe maybe he had like a really
a lot a lot and maybe the position is
not that hard so he figured it out but
yeah what I'm saying having an hour on
the clock I would probably but if they
would have taken more time to make
absolutely I mean yeah it's obviously
huge and you're either you're either
drawing now you're in the draw zone or
you've completely thrown the game away
so yeah very interesting so we're gonna
definitely be coming back to this one
seeing if Hans Neiman can somehow hold
it this is going to be a huge one for
the standings as well okay
what else do we have what else do we
have no results just yet right let's
quickly click through the games and
figure out if they all pass the time
control that's move 37 for operating
actually okay
making those moves
that's the current position on the board
so it's a rook end game with other Pawn
we are talking about and still I'm not
convinced black will easily save this
one if white is trying to win does white
actually want to swap the Bishops I
would have thought maybe you want to
keep Bishops on the board yeah like
ideally you probably do want to keep the
Bishops but that's that's a very good
Bishop right and G2 Pawn is targeted
it's a your your options are pretty much
Bishop F3 or take on e4 and out of those
two you you do take on e4 right so in
other words a good defense by black
perhaps
yeah say something like that and then
yeah once again even H4 G5 takes takes
G4 is the funny he's a funny setup
because
next movie C4 and the King somehow
useless yeah it cannot cannot really
attack the room yeah so imagine why it
goes C4 and then runs with the King
towards this Pawn so it can be just
automatically winning ah
so like really really tricky and that's
move 37 operating still thinking he he
is in huge trouble
all right definitely okay you Yang Yi oh
well that that's one crazy position but
it's okay yeah this is yeah it seems
that uh White has it under control so a
check and Queenie tree was played so he
himself wouldn't mind checkmating the
black king a check here King F1 Rook G6
okay creating a square for the king I
guess yes planning to run to each side
and Bishop E4 and Bishop E4 somehow is a
very strong move Bishop E4 Bishop E4 was
played now
94. I can just just get the Knight
closer as well possibly to G3 F5
uh rookie 7 is a threat in some
positions yeah things are not looking
very good
things are not looking very good for
black
so Nicholas just like a second ago
looked like it was under like a little
bit of pressure and now all of a sudden
it's just kind of flipped on its head
and it's like oh yeah when he's always
had it he's always been under control
did he win just three in a row younger I
mean considering he wins he wins this
one so he started relatively slow and
then I think this is how he's he's done
this before he won the the 2022 Summer
Classic if I remember right he lost the
first game in that one and then just
battled his way all the way back it
feels like I don't know sometimes these
the strongest players in the field it
feels like they do so well at the very
end of the tournaments and I don't know
if that's just like better stamina or if
they're you know I don't know just
random or do you think there's actually
something there did stronger players are
they stronger because they just like
doing better at the end maybe they're
stronger you know
right what's going on but really
nowadays even like in magnus's case it's
very rarely a blowout so he starts five
out of five and so on yeah so it's much
more often that yeah he has this little
bit of energy left when nobody else has
right so maybe that's maybe that's the
case or well with you and Yi that that
seems what the thing that happens right
now
he loves coming behind and winning those
last several games winning tournaments
that way so let's move 37 and this might
as well be like finished right after
they've reached me 40 because black king
isn't a huge amount of trouble uh versus
Ganguly
[Music]
a lot of stuff happened and yeah it does
look winning for white yeah fun to win
trying to catch up with the leader yep
so his point is yeah this Pawn will cost
black a rook black spawn perhaps will
cost me a bishop but then my king is
much closer to the remaining point so
this looks absolutely winning for white
and yeah and Neiman's game uh someone
posted in the chat uh video it has B5
only winning oh okay so that's always so
it's actually interesting though I mean
if I don't know what the computer says
he had opened a second ago but sometimes
these like these particular kinds of end
games if it's minus one or minus two
like still even then like sometimes it's
not quite like winning but it could be
it obviously very very easily might be
but on the other hand I mean what's the
other moves that if not B5 I mean you
know like but still waiting B5 is the
most tempting move I would say so still
out yeah
there's another Temptation I don't know
you might grab the pawn we we may say 50
chance
B5 or or not correct yeah once you see
B5 though it does look like how do you
not play it once you see it yeah
all right definitely we'll keep our eye
we'll be watching this one
it's a very good chance yeah and the B
group the B group not a single result
here beautiful uh Christian Christian
is when we kind of flip-flopped oh wait
a second I mean he didn't get any of
those spawns I mean what what happened
what happens no Bishop G3 was my silly
analysis so instead no no no
all right
need to go back to this one yeah okay
finally finally Rook F4 Bishop A7 he
perhaps was very nah he wasn't long on
time King back to D7 and that's a very
unpleasant move to make rookie one
Bishop D6 Bishop C5 but now who's
winning
and and why yes that's always the tough
part I want to say still I want to say
push the C Pawn that's the best you can
do but now with Bishop being traded it's
not already not that tricky right
stockfish says it's back to equal uh
Bishop takes F5 ah yeah so we are still
talking hans's game that's all they talk
about
if you see any move in the chat it's the
Hans game
all right so that that's the one for
general I'm not even sure what uh what
happens there
uh hopefully yeah C3 Rook to C1 and then
what you do is a check King girls Rook
C4 and with Rook behind the puzzle is
this still good for Christian though
um I don't think he's winning not as
good obviously yeah I don't think he's
uh winning any longer but yeah he
shouldn't be shouldn't be like
shouldn't be lost uh we did minus two
people yeah once again we gotta go back
but that's exactly what E5 was played is
what oh wait a second but that's exactly
what you were talking about that uh
minus two in this end game might be
nothing
it's like you have to go you have to go
deep it actually means yes black is two
pawns up right so it's material oppon up
and then you know better so if computer
would see how those pawns promote and
win the bishop that'd be minus infinity
give you a number it's minus 60 uh right
so therefore it does look very appealing
with the pawn on B3 and ability to say
play H5 or something but what I'm saying
it's still not done right right
I mean we can we can go pretty deep on
this one's correct H5 is correct it
could be strangely enough now that I'm
thinking it could be that black is kind
of tempo short
no my point is King F7 and you promise
to pass and then I go G6 and at least I
have two past pawns on the other side of
the board right right and then yeah I'm
still not convinced this is winning but
at least there is a chat but black white
won't pass you go H5
he'll go H5 and now if the king is far
enough let's say on D5 then there's
always going to be this H6 Bishop takes
and then while it's very likely to trade
his F Pawn for the remaining black ball
so can we just put a bunch of moves on
the board let's let this King try to run
all the way in and let's see yeah let's
just follow what stockfish has to say
yeah so it's Bishop to C2
and it used to say plus three just a
second ago okay so it's something like I
guess probably minus three minus three
uh Bishop B2 Bishop D3 but look let's do
it let's see if the starfish can win
this yeah look what it's doing
I mean it's kind of okay runs that way
King runs that way okay Bishop back okay
so at least to see
to see what the point is I and it goes
wow here a completely different idea
yeah so the bishop has to be to be
pinned down to kind of stop the B Pawn
and the [ __ ] enters this way and then
this stupid King it gets to look it gets
to H5 and combined with Bishop D3 oh
white drops one of the pawns so white
also has to have this idea anymore oh my
and yeah and now we don't even know if
it's possible or not because it still
changes what it has to say I mean it's
yeah like if this happens if the Kings
only three and Bishop E2 happens which
we do happens black is winning but could
white possibly somehow prevent it this
much we don't know because here for
instance machine all of a sudden starts
capturing H5 okay and Bishop F5 and I
would expect this one to be winning
right on purpose to be honest because
that's like yeah that's uh two two past
pawns and also an ability to go to D1 to
capture this guy but yeah
all right so I mean all right obviously
we're keeping our eye on this one a lot
of different ways some crazy engine
lines that maybe are winning maybe not
we still are kind of keeping in our eye
here but we have a ton of results uh we
have results in the uh Von win game we
have results in the Yu Yang Yi game one
win we have a lot of wins these are our
tournament leaders so okay wins against
Ganguly and once again I'll not go over
the entire game but it turns out the
moment we tuned in the moment we tuned
in uh black could have played a five
guard the square not let the king run
over there and this would have been just
a marginal age for white and Bishop F4
King E4 tends to be absolutely lost yeah
okay and we saw specifically use this
specifically because of yes okay now if
the bishop goes away I presume all this
plan that I've described yeah the King
goes and then you know yeah so black
tried to go kind of Rogue mode
King C4 engage into some you know some
born races but there is no Race White is
by India Faster by a mile very king of
67 very strong so this is where this
game came to itself that's the end yeah
congrats to uh Von Nguyen he was sitting
at three and a half he was a half Point
behind coming into this so he has gone
all the way up to four and a half now
but Yu Yang Yi was also one of the
leaders on four points
and he has one so he manages to keep the
lead in this event so now let me see and
this one was interesting too we've been
talking about it because yeah it's like
he was under a little bit of pressure
but maybe he never was maybe he always
said everything because all that despite
this one looking at the scary it never
was in Black's favor
okay so it's around equal light Plus for
white round equal and then F3
the move that we initially liked a lot
it looks scary it was it wasn't that
great it turns out it wasn't that great
it turns out yes it's like
what I meant was
remember the material after workouts or
something yeah so if three captures uh a
brilliant with Rook takes B7 okay Queen
H6 rugby six
um even compi agrees that yeah you
should take
um The Pawn on D7 and not the bishop
Rook takes and Rook takes is a big
mistake Queen takes was better but then
if Queen takes apparently we're no
longer talking about the attack yeah
it's just tries Consolidated still kind
of plus one for white but yeah what can
you do yeah Rook F6 this all out thing
apparently was not working
yeah a check Queen E3 Rook G6 that's
what we've seen Knight D4 a check yeah
he was also very short on time time Rook
uh yeah queen of tree so that's brutal
not even like trying to attack the king
I mean he says man I'm I'm just winning
quite a few pawns up yeah and yeah and
he one couldn't be one resigning
immediately because it's here it drops
at night with the check and then perhaps
the Checkmate is he's somewhere near so
it's yeah it's incredible and I want to
actually know did you like think maybe
during the game did you ever think that
he was under time pressure or what I
don't know but we have an interview so
maybe we'll get to know that interview
and let's listen to you and see what he
had to say about his game
all right I'm here with you Yang Yi
fresh office Victory against Nicholas
Theodore you just had a great game you
know you want to tell me all about it oh
okay it's a game a very interesting game
yeah big yeah
is no more yes
yeah the necessary if yeah yeah a long
sink yeah with me I don't know yeah very
interesting idea because sometimes
Bishop December would be three next
maybe rupee six I don't know
create it
history to create technical F4 it should
be the queen D4 here if you black Play
Bishop a take C5 position over C7 take
and take Queen D2 I think what is better
yeah okay maybe can't feel this
oh
[Music]
before
okay
Bishop F6
207 C5 C5
yeah maybe bishop D4 is better yeah
Bishop F5 root diva looks like white is
dangerous I don't know just see
shall we see if I play Bishop CS5 maybe
slightly mistake I don't know he shall
we have for this uh we are with d8 maybe
interesting
mm-hmm
over three
take take Ruby seven
I missed screenshot six I think the
queen G6 could move here here along very
important
session because
if you play V1 Knight G4 H3 E3
but he's lost
on Ruby 6 only move yes
here if you plug play Community for
refseq Queen G4
take take with it what is winning
97 oh
yes here up 36 95
A1
maybe white is okay but looks very
dangerous I play uf6 here my opponent
maybe
is blunder uf6 stick yeah only move
Queen F6 take take
um Bishop D1 okay
because
uh my opponent name is Queen hs3 and
naive or rage 6 Quincy Street check King
Jay to Queen C7 yes
okay
you have six pancake tick tick
cringe for who you are
Ctrl E5
original six check
which is a case three take careful
there's a position where his winning
position he shot before
protect
which is oh sorry
catch one okay
six three yes my opponent blunder could
be what because the Korean history is
lost tonight okay
uh well that's going to be an amazing
game for me that's going to put you up
at Five Points now going into the next
round how are you feeling yes
um my reaction yes
well that's great to hear you Angie uh
we look forward to seeing more chess
from you in the previous games
that was you Yang Yi and this might be a
huge result for the a group because now
he is sitting in the soul lead he was
coming into today he had four points
just like Gregory o'para he wins but
Oparin might actually be in a little bit
of danger it could be a situation where
we have two Soul leaders when this day
is over a lot has been happening yeah
absolutely
um so indeed a foreign is in quite a bit
of trouble it's a rook end game for only
one pull-up for only one sometimes
that's all you need yeah like sometimes
it's not enough as well yeah yeah but
this is another one too but just to give
like an example of like a position a
computer might not fully be able to
trust is somebody winning or not
sometimes these kinds of interesting I'm
here computer claims that yeah I wasn't
sure so once again I picked up the
computer's valuation if it says plus
three in the position but dangerous one
extra Pawn that means that white makes
progress not only he's a pawn up but he
will make progress in foreseeable future
absolutely so this is looking very bad
for Gregory o'parin who came into the
day again tied with you Yang Yi you
actually won apparent is in a lot of
danger so this could mean quite a lot
for the tournament yeah but of course
the game of the day let's let's Lance
this incredible game let's see and I
guess not in Hans kind of got tricked no
okay so we did get to this position so
Bishop B2 sure hg4 King G4 King H7 as
well uh not yet I mean currently that's
the position that's the position so
white I presume I mean you don't have
much to do but to take it King FS King
H7
and I was thinking yeah okay but what do
you do if a black weight right you can't
move your Bishop anymore
and it's you can't really move your king
it's getting dicey yeah
so
you'll have to go H5 perhaps
but then once again then black gives a
check you don't want to be dropping this
once again H4 and then again evading
myth because now it's so strange those
two songs right I mean I know there's no
such one never mind here you can
actually yeah yeah you can actually go
back and give a check so hang on a
second that one we actually missed we
felt close to that Yeah we actually
missed the win we missed the win which
was give a check first
okay okay
so now we go okay
yeah okay let's look at the game um
[Music]
imagine this one with white to move King
H3 is still a move so it's been a bit
out of shit's torment so I wanted to
plan
with the say King on it yeah but that's
kind of elusive win you know yeah
it gives minus five and then ah no wait
just kidding it was I can't figure it
out yeah and I saw someone in the chat I
mean said you know they're running maybe
a deeper engine they got to depth 80 or
something not very hard to do I guess in
a position this simplified but even then
the computer was a little confused it's
kind of this wild one where it's like
all righty I don't know is Hans losing
is he not and that's what the first time
I believe during your coverage is for
whatever reason well the audience is a
lot a lot of people but not very active
in the chat so first time restream
awarded me some page saying 100
passengers today thanks very much guys
for being so active yes and also did you
know on YouTube when you click the like
button now there's confetti yeah it's so
funny we're at 45 likes if you want to
hit the button you can make it explode
code it's so much fun hit the like
button it's really cool now
okie dokie so two very tricky end games
right the bishop Bishop D1 was already
played King went to G3 and for what we
now plaque is kind of winning but even
computer is not show not sure how
exactly does he do it it worked we got a
lot of likes yeah that that was cool
that was cool
um the B tournament
the B tournament we do have a first
result and this is a draw for Christian
okay for Christian and coverage and
that's a that's a funny position to look
at because there is no King
where did they go last move was King E4
King takes
so once again yeah a reminder I said
games are played on the digital board
right and whenever you move the piece it
reduces the move so we get those live
moves and show and analyze but it shows
up like he ate the king yeah and then
the very end of the game the draw agreed
and in order to register this draw they
have to put the kings in the you know
then in orbital perhaps yeah so I
believe the correct way of doing it
would be to lift black king first kind
of remove it and then put the white King
on e4 then put the black king on E5 but
never mind yeah so that's what happened
and then yeah like
it's white white realize he's a king
down black realized yeah I'm winning but
uh how do I supposed to Checkmate my
opponent he has no King and therefore
draws
all right
and then we have Lindemann whoa who is a
very active pieces including the King on
H4
uh that still looks very actually good
yeah it actually gets very exciting uh
counting the pawns
it's equal now and black can even take a
three next move so apparently London has
some idea of attack attacking the king
feels believable but where is it yeah it
does but yeah exactly
how do you actually I believe it how do
you actually you tell me where it is now
how do you actually get there uh maybe
let's yeah let's go like a few moves
back that's exactly yeah the scenario
that I was describing right it's a B6
kick the Knight away and he voluntarily
goes Bishop F7 in order to have this C5
thread right yeah and white went with G5
okay into D5 traded through G1 Rook G8
queen of fade it's an awkward yeah
awkward way of defunding the king but
then the Rook gets active
so Knight to E4 a check and Bishop E8
white girls H5
not sure what would have happened if
Bishop takes H5 maybe some night ah yeah
that's actually some brilliant stuff
background Queen incursions yeah Queen
sneaking in and Checkmate on G8 and
that's why you actually need the
bishopone E8 so it blocks like blocks
the Yates rank physically being coming
in right King H4 and what happens if
Rook A3 let's say okay I understand it's
naive and probably will never be played
but yes a white apparently is winning
with some Knight D6 and why is that
it's hard to tell it's hard to tell well
that's right I can't understand the
threat right take the bishop ah yeah and
whenever you move the bishop Knight F7
wins immediately kind of right you can
as long as basically the White Queen to
sneak in they can sneak in either way or
Rook G6 yeah like everything Rook G6
wins Knight F7 wins Yeah so basically
you need to join the action with the
queen and that's that's winning
and apparently it is already winning
after King H4 no matter what okay so
yeah I believe in this could be I mean
landerman is gonna be running away with
this with the win here he came in a
point ahead of the field I mean with two
games left he could be two points ahead
of everybody I mean this this is just
huge stuff
uh
once my opinion on chirilla competing
uh wants my opinion I've been in his
shoes like trying to play one of those
fall Classics back in 2018 and it didn't
go he didn't go well for me it's kind of
a crazy question what do you expect to
say we're against it like what do you
expect somebody to say it's great it's
awesome
he should stick to commentary oh it's
awesome it's been wonderful seeing them
yeah he's put together some wins the
point is like it's really rough coming
back to professional play absolutely
even if you you have you know you have
been into chess like it's it's not like
he quit to play I don't know baseball or
ice Hulk here right but I mean it was
always around commentating training and
so on but it's not the same thing it's
not the same animal you're a
professional player and you're training
for yourself or you I don't know
teaching kids or maybe even working with
the strong players but on his say his
demands his questions and on a serious
level it's very admirable because you
know like when you get to like a certain
rating and you might not be at that
anymore it's very easy to be like I'm
done I'm taking the gloves off I'm not
going to fight it that's what I'm doing
because nobody nobody enjoys losing
their name so yeah it's been great
seeing Christian play
yeah okay so Lenderman seemingly is
winning and we absolutely have to check
how is uh the game of Christopher you oh
yeah this was a big one that's the one
that's the one Jennifer was in trouble
it probably still it still is yeah
that's uh like
everything's winning we are in a I
believe in a table based territory okay
so we know the answer for sure table
based territory okay one little thing to
mention which probably doesn't really
anything here right but with the King on
F7 and no F Pawn and Bishop elsewhere
and potential it's a drone it's a draw
it was discovered uh like at the time
where there was no no there were no
engines and so on I think between Nick
I'm guessing
yeah
so it was a Jordan game back in the day
and then they had lines
kind of specifically went for this setup
like being done down the Poland exchange
and it happened to be a draw but but
yeah but here you're gonna have an extra
a bonus F Pawn so white task should be
trivial because you are allowed to
exchange these guys for the bishop and
just make sure that you have the
opposition in the in the final position
absolutely right so it should be it
should be more than more than easy yeah
I don't know by the way why he went
I'm guessing the easiest way would be to
just take this round
basically so you just go with four so
that your Rook does not well your Rook
will never be disturbed Pawn on F4
cannot be taken because then just attack
the seventh rank go of seven so
literally I just go with four
and like sweating and just give King D4
yeah takes Rook D7 okay you think
something like that I still play Rook D7
so that would be pretty pretty
straightforward you know the kind of
schematic thinking and nothing can stop
me from getting the king to E7 yeah so
that's but anyway anyway there is no
doubt he's gonna win there's no doubt
he's all right so Christopher might be
losing this one gurgly kantar maybe
perhaps getting a very big win here and
uh speaking of big wins we do have we
showed the game with Von Nguyen who now
is a half Point behind you Yang Yi in
the top uh and the a group and we're
actually going to be able to see his
thoughts on the game because we have yet
another interview let's check it out all
right
all right I am here with Grandmaster and
then fresh off his victory off of Grand
Master gone ghouli and tell me all about
your win take me through it and show me
the sauce man
yeah okay let's look at the game uh
today I played with white against
Ganguly
um
who has been a bit out of shape this
tournament so I wanted to play not too
aggressively but I wanted a game so I
decided to go E4 and we played the
Italian uh Knight of 63 it's all normal
and here he surprised me on move 4
already I was out of book he played D5
which I hadn't looked at in around two
years already but uh okay he takes Z5 as
Force Knight takes D5 short Castle
Bishop E7 Rook E1 and F6
so um the point of this line is to
not study all the subtleties of Italian
because it's quite a complex opening and
there are many setups for white for
black it's quite uh it's very
complicated so he decided to prepare a
very direct line which has a reputation
of being slightly worse but on the other
hand it puts the pressure on white to
really he has to play quite precise to
keep the edge because it's quite forcing
what black is doing
so here I know that there's C3 there's
H3 I remember C3 Bishop G4
and something like H3 Bishop H5 Bishop
B3 and it's interesting but it's quite a
big fight and um today uh although I
wanted to fight he was well prepared so
I decided to go for the most direct line
which is D4 I vaguely remembered uh
Knight P6 Bishop P3 Knight D4 Knight E4
Queen D4 Queen D4 e D4 this end game is
supposed to be okay for black but uh
white doesn't run much risk so I went
Bishop F4 Bishop F5 so here I was
wondering
um if I cannot go A4 it's quite an
interesting move and here I thought that
maybe he'll go let's say King D7
I can go A5 kick his Knight Knight C8
um but I assumed that he's still in
preparation maybe I have C3 here or
Knight E2 I'm not sure but um again I'm
pawned down and he's prepared so because
he's been blitzing out every move until
now so I decided to just second C7 make
life simple and after King D7 to go
Knight D2
um now I think he went the only logical
move Bishop C5
and uh yeah here I can go first Bishop
takes Ace B6 A6 B6
and let's say Knight E4 but here he is
not forced to take on e4 I thought maybe
he'll go like Rook to E8 and it feels
quite rawish Knight G3 Bishop G6 I
didn't see why I should be better he has
a pair of Bishops I have uh a better
Pawn structure so it doesn't look clear
so instead I went Knight E4
um and uh
here
um the interesting line is Bishop B4 uh
he's he could have gone for that Bishop
takes B6 Bishop takes E1
but here I have uh Bishop A4 check and
it might seem that black is losing but I
was actually wondering if I have
anything at all because after Bishop A4
checked in E6
um so first of all Rook takes E1 doesn't
really work because ATX P6 Knight G3
check King F7
um his Bishop's hanging but my Bishop's
also hanging so after Bishop B3 he can
just go King G6 and he's uh he's
probably winning
so um instead after Bishop A4 checking
is six
um I can at least go Bishop B3 and he
has to go back to D7
um I was a bit worried that he might do
this because it felt to me like just a
draw but okay I was gonna think a
computer is suggesting Bishop takes D4
after King E6 and the game still goes on
it's probably around equal
um instead he just took on e4 uh on move
15 which surprised me and I was actually
very happy to see this because of the
bishop B6 ab6 Rook takes E4 although
it's opposite color of Bishops
um I have net share because I have a
better Pawn structure and it's not easy
for him to deal with some concrete
issues so he went B5 because Rook to E8
I just take on the 8 and he cannot
recapture with the Rook because of
Bishop A4
so it's a bit unpleasant that's why he
went P5 rook ae1 and I think here uh he
really should have made life simpler for
him and gone rookie 8 although it's a
bit sad uh to go rookie 8 Rook takes C8
Rook takes E8 Rook taxi 18 takes E8
um because he gives up a pawn let's say
Bishop D5 but I think here it's very
strong for him to go let's say B4 Bishop
takes B7 and D3 which is critical and C
takes D3 uh Bishop T4 B3 and this
position although he's two pawns down um
I think it's just a draw because he can
go F5 followed by G6 and King comes F6
it's I think it's a fortress
I have analyzed similar positions from
other openings and this motive with the
B4 D3 and Bishop D4 I've seen before and
usually it's just a draw so that's why
Rook to E8 is
from what I I think it's the best
movement that should lead to a draw
however he um he was a bit worried maybe
it's
like possible to lose so he went Rook 88
keeping on his pawns but now I went H4
expanding and here's some weaknesses on
the king side
tc7h5 just fixing the king side H6 was a
very bad move I thought like here I
think D3 was supposed to be played C
takes D3 I would have gone Rook takes D3
Rook G4 and Rook D7 and I am better but
it's not clear how to proceed
instead he went H6 which I was now I was
getting quite optimistic in fact so I
went Rook G4 Rook D7 df1 Rook hd8 so I
understood that he wants Bishop f8
uh he wants to go [ __ ] perfect followed
by D3 and free his Rook from the defense
of the G7 Pawn that's why I decided to
go Bishop E6 Rook E7 Bishop to F5
trade one pair of Rooks but now um
here's some concrete issues so if he
goes Bishop f8 then I'll just come with
the King to D3 and pick up the D4 Pawn
so that's why he played Rook to E8 check
instead King F1 Rook E7 and now A3 and
this is very unpleasant because
um
she can either give up the pawn like in
the game or he can after a three go
let's say Bishop B6 I would go let's say
B4
and King C6 Bishop D3 I mean he's no
pawns down but
everything is like Rook has to defend G7
Bishop has to defend D4 and the King has
to defend P5 so um he has no moves no
counter play and I'll just come slowly
with the King to G6 and probably it's
going to be lost although it's still not
so simple because my king is cut off and
it's not easy to get to G6 but I think
it should be winning so he played
practice he went B4 and move 27 8xp4
Bishop takes P4 C3 hit like this I gain
upon Bishop C5 C takes D4 Bishop B4 F3
and here probably objectively it should
be a draw but I'm Pawn up for free and
after King D6 I want D5 Bishop D2 Bishop
E6 my Bishop sits very nicely on E6
here he went correct because I want to
go either Rook A4 or Rook C4 and uh
and attack the G7 Pawn from behind so he
went B5 thing E2 Bishop C1
Rook B4 King C5 Rook B3 this was a very
logical sequence I thought before in
King D3 and here it's a very nasty
position because let's say he makes a
move which looks logical like Rook A7 on
move 37 then he would lose because I
would go G3 and his Bishop would be
trapped F5 F4 and I just go King C2 and
collect this bishop
so that's why after King D3 He Went
Bishop F4 he saw um the threat but it's
probably also blunder
um it's what computer says I mean here
after King D3 it's already very tricky I
thought but Bishop F4 I went King E4
if you go Bishop D6 here I just go let's
say
F4 or King F5 and King goes to G6 it
should be lost
so instead he won Bishop E5 I went F4
and uh yeah I mean if he just sits tight
I just go King to G6 and it should be
slowly winning so here the last Stitch
attempt with King C4 because here it's
my 40th move and I had not much time so
I had to calculate precisely
here I have two options Rook takes B4 or
F text E5 both should be winning but F
takes E5 I calculated was really clean
because of the king takes P3 ef6 gf6
King F5 although he has his own past
Pawn after King takes B2 but my Pawn is
just way too fast D6 Rook E8 King takes
F6 and he resigned here because let's
say B3 t7 let's say Rook T8 or I don't
know doesn't matter let's say Rook h8
King E7 King C3
I can take on B3 and um
in the opponent game I'll just be too
fast and uh yeah two against one and
eventually all Queen so uh so he just
resigned after King takes F6 and uh yeah
that was my game
four and a half points is obviously an
amazing score you're gonna be playing
Nicholas Theodore tomorrow with the
black pieces how are you doing about
that matchup well uh it's going to be an
interesting game I hope
um I don't know him too well
um it's the first time I think I see him
at a chess tournament but I know that
he's quite a strong online player and
his rating is around 2600 so yeah I'm
looking forward to the game and let's
see what happens all right thanks for
having us thanks for coming on and we
hope to see you uh back and see you soon
yeah thanks
well that was tie-dye Von to win with
that win now he'll be at four and a half
points a half points behind the leader
so this is a competitor to really keep
our eye on now traditionally this is
where our show generally starts to wrap
up but I think we still have some things
to look forward to and I'd like to just
keep the show going and maybe we can
keep our eye particularly on that Hans
game I don't know if there's been any
changes in it or what Hans is obviously
struggling maybe can hold on maybe can't
uh the king did run it looks like the
way that Kudo I thought was a little
more human so not the stockfish approach
no no no well will it actually kind of
did try the stock wish approach okay Han
was Hans was precise with Bishop C1 and
waiting on H3 the one that we figured
out yeah so that's if black attempts to
do something like that white has in the
kind of
yeah here and then the king starts to
run in the opposite direction but it's
also dangerous now for white with the
bishop black Bishop being on D1 because
remember I was talking with uh the
bishop on Long diagonal white would have
a source of corn to play like H5 this
isn't taken away from it maybe yeah
maybe not with the bishop on D1 you
actually do not have an access to this
one
king E7 check from here King D7 kidney
force and now he's what he's running
yeah into a square of this Pawn or
something right no but he cannot right
now Bishop C2 pushes the king back but
then H5 is interesting okay so if King
C6 then then what can he already pledge
five yes because F Pawn cannot be
guarded right so it does lose the edge
Pawn but then Bishops
he's crazy wow it might be still winning
you know with some like voretsky style
stuff Bishops Bishop F7 then H5 and
Bishop is in one diagonal stopping the F
Pawn and holding the kind of protecting
the H4 oh man actually a very very
tricky and insanely tricky this is like
one of the hardest end games we've seen
yeah that's a very tricky what do you
think the odds are like is Hans gonna
hold this like if he had to put I don't
know a percentage on it what are the
chances that Hans makes a draw
um
more than 50 right I believe more than
50 percent he has shown already like
like yeah he identified the threat here
here
still and another interesting
conversation so Chad was mentioning the
disparity on the clocks I'd see this is
the corner of my eye we can see that Han
still has 47 minutes fitted around 12
minutes overall is the correct approach
or if you're defending this as white to
try to move as fast as you can put as
much pressure on the opponent to come up
with these hard ideas as quickly as
possible or do you still want to take
your time and you know play accurately I
didn't know you do I don't know so there
could be two possible reasons for Hans
playing fast because
well options I mean possibilities are
this is a draw
and then you kind of figured out the way
how the Fortress works and you don't
care any longer right I mean and you
just play fast because you know okay if
you go here I have to go here it's
understandable alternatively he might
actually see some dangerous way that he
is not sure how to make a draw and then
perhaps what you can do because white
defense is still limited right it's not
like white has any sort of oh let's play
this crazy water attacking move I mean
you Shuffle the bishop on like two
squares and and the King has to guard
the pawn all the time so if you figured
out that black actually has some attempt
that you are not sure how to make a draw
against you probably start kind of
trying to apply at least some time
pressure and so on and you know you see
it confidently and you move this bishop
to C1 and back to A3 and like why are we
still playing it's a draw don't you see
we will stay on the air until this one
is over but I know we maybe do have some
results uh particularly in the B section
I believe
yeah results in the B section let's find
out landemon wins and confirmed as the
Soul Leader
by at least two points I'm actually
wondering if yeah so he's he's two
points clear of both raunak and
Christopher yeah yeah so Christopher you
lost today so that's gonna be two points
over Christopher you but could it be
that someone else
ahead yeah so theoretically there's two
more days somebody could still catch him
and force the playoff uh reminder
two days ago those three were tied for
the first time
had no plans of slowing down he won both
games and his Rivals Lost Boys amazing
so we can take a look at the last few
movies yeah but last remaining moves H5
and King went to H4 C5 and yeah so
basically black couldn't really figure
out the way to stop Knight D6 maybe
there was no way of stopping this bishop
D7 and he ran into Rook G6 and
uh once again how does he win in this
case ah just girls Rook G4 and check and
uh Rook G6 and King G4 because at first
I wasn't sure like yeah the ah5 pawn is
still alive this one spinned right so
sure it's almost like you can take the
Rook on G6 but almost doesn't count yep
so very nice for Lenderman who is I mean
the very clear favorite to win the me
section we in fact in B tournament we
only have one game going it's Chandra
against harutinyan and here uh well once
again a lot of stuff happened that's a
position that apparently has to be
winning for black with an extra night
for a pawn but sometimes those uh you
know those end games on One Wing and one
on say you know everything on a king
side and white still has kind of a
flexible structure so no major
weaknesses they might be tricky there
might be tricky because there's always
potential that white starts swapping the
pawns and you're left with like crooked
Knight against rookies not enough yeah
uh all right so let's go to hans's game
I think that that's the one that will be
concentrating on just uh yeah the bishop
Bishop C2 king of four king to C6 is
what we have
currently so this H5 possible here do we
start with the bishop to B2 yeah I mean
we could
we could start with Bishop to B2 as
we're allowing Bishop D1 there's like
probably ah hang on a second you might
be right yes after Bishop B2 it might be
very clever for black to go Bishop D1
because after this you you probably have
the will have the same position but
which with King being much more wrecked
so you can go to C5 let's say yeah like
check here Bishop back and then you can
give this check right and yeah the king
F4 King D3 now yeah H5 will be certainly
too late right because yeah running out
of time for this
captures captures and then how do we do
it well actually Bishop H5 now I'm 100
sure is clever 100 sure it's clever
because you'll go here no seriously
you'll go here
he's still not in time to take this
right so but you'll go here and you go
H5 and then white has no contact line
and you win the bishop and whenever he
gets to F7 you take one F7 the H pile so
maybe in this position it can white get
away with like H5 H6 and now yeah maybe
maybe let's try H5 immediately
I guess we're just assuming black forces
us to play H6 or something or or you can
improve the king yeah you probably still
run with the King kind of up aboard and
isn't it very different now that I'm
thinking it's funny different oh yeah
yeah why this way white kind of wins
uh White wins a couple of Tempe right
for this line because the bishop is on
C2 and yeah and let's kind of highlight
the difference but baby king C4 was no
yeah King C4 I had to do
captures here
Bishop F6 I think this will be
first of all it's kind of I don't see
them harder harder for black to get
there yeah I don't have okay say he goes
still still try attempts the same yeah
stay with them's the same Bishop B2
Bishop page five
he's stealing time I know King E5 right
Bishop he
ate
it's very tricky indeed so dsh5 King E7
manages to even push the bishop away
from kind of embarrassing push the
bishop away from this diagonal but then
uh we are entering like new territory
because this Pawn can still start
running but also you can kill Bishop C6
Bishop D5 and this is just winning yeah
yeah
yeah I'm good it's looking like
everything might work out for black here
uh it's getting harder and harder to see
how hot this holds this one H five yeah
so that that's what that's the one we
have on the board okay so this was in
ccxh5 uh well the good thing though is
[Music]
it cannot last forever this game because
civility is like five minutes only and
that that's the most exciting perhaps I
understand like we are do you think he's
sweating it or do you think he's just
he's just happy to work it all out
chilling how does vidit feel right now
how does video feel
um I'm guessing once again I mean
yeah figure it out for me but uh just
speculating honestly like if I would
have a game like this then someone in
Middle game obviously I felt like yeah
okay it's all coming coming kind of
together and probably much better and so
on so I'd be disappointed when say we
get this opposite colored Bishops and
with the Rooks and I'm probably kind of
lost all of my advantage so now I'm
actually very excited I mean this moment
so it's amazing still maybe I still win
maybe maybe it happens yes do you like
that feeling or do you do you have any
worry in the back of your mind like you
know what I might be messing this all
out I might not be fine I'll message a
Discounter like I I should be winning
but I'm not gonna find it do you have
that fear in the back of your mind
really because you're happy to have a
winning position no seriously I believe
this one comes as the bonus because you
already had like a very promising
position that your opponent bailed
himself out yeah okay probably had a
draw at some point so now you you're
more relaxed in a way okay so if it's
your first attempt that we also from the
first chance of winning this position
then you got that word right then you're
probably more stressed yeah so Bishop to
D1 happened so now yeah he absolutely
has to go I mean the other option was
bringing the king closer immediately but
he plays yeah once again he he has this
idea yeah let's see let's see if he
finds it by the way
so let's yeah because I keep insisting
with the stupid Bishop H5 let's uh show
why it is important
all right so say this
King D3 how we gonna do it
black always has it that does the thing
like black always has a king D3 let's
say white weights King C2
white Waits
just yeah no I wanted to to show how it
doesn't work for for black like but yeah
the only way you stop the F Pawn it's
always going to be like Bishop on F7
Pawn on H5 yeah so in fact it might be
easier winning than uh-huh
all right so there are yeah the
variation is somewhat depressing
minus 8.8 on not so deep stock so we
have this six-man table base here if we
had these seven man table base we would
have the absolute certainty of knowing
that's more dudes yeah uh Bishop Bishop
F6 is going to make it the moment he
captures the pawn is going to make it uh
the table and then we can declare that
there is one and only one winning move
for black mm-hmm
are really so that that's what people
say that's what it says I'm cheating I'm
looking at your computer right there
yeah King C4
ah King C4 is winning and all the rest
is but what's all the rest I mean that
kind of once again table base is funny
in a way Bishop H5 is not going to get
it done
I'm not gonna get it done why is that
because anything is draw it says but
hang on a second if I go here no I mean
I do believe the table base but it's
just a few as well what's wrong they're
trying to move
ah he blocks me from entering with the
queen okay this is an important defense
look and then yeah and then white kind
of standstill does nothing and only yeah
like so now you need to the Bone to move
oh okay so now finally I'll be able to
illustrate what I meant when I said like
the principle one diagonal right so now
in order to actually move this King away
because you'll never be able to approach
that way it's not again right like kind
of King on E6 will be met with King F4
so it's it's sort of a guarding shoulder
ring right and in order to distract the
skin you'll have to move the pawn the H
Pawn right or wait a second yeah white
one so this is important
yeah and then the king comes close huh
and yeah but now now you can distract
that Bishop with the other Bishop parade
some two diagonals and then you'll be
able to push F7 distract the bishop
capture the H board there you go so it
is actually there are some ways
together and What's the diff ah and the
difference here it's actually very
subtle so now I go to C4 I really do try
to go to D3 so it's got a tempo-ish end
game strangely enough after King E3 I
can play Bishop C2 and white is not on
time to capture H6 because the B dude
will still promote it's the same thing I
got a guard two diagonals with my Bishop
this time yeah always learning
all right so there I mean
even with table base you know you still
got to work all this stuff out these
guys don't have a table base he's under
two minutes and Divinity is on the two
minutes and he has one winning move uh
wait a second I claim so that's more
than 50 percent uh for Hans to escape
now I reduce the probability of 50 it's
either he makes something makes it makes
it draw or he does no I mean I mean this
kind of fifty percent I mean they're
well-known meme I believe yeah the
probability of This Is 50 yeah that
makes a drawn I mean two options yes
those are that's basically it and we
will see we are easily waiting that's
how low probability Works uh meanwhile
gambian wins against Gregorio Parian so
we can confirm that you young is the
sole leader oh my gosh yes by half a
point right Von Nguyen is sitting at uh
yep four and a half points you Yang Yi
is at five we can actually probably take
a quick look at the standings here in
just a second uh just to kind of show
what we're talking about
but
I just kidding we will get the standings
here momentarily but first we're
actually going to have an interview with
Alex Slenderman and then we'll come back
and have another look at this Hans game
to see what's happening there enjoy this
interview
we'll get you that Alex Slenderman
interview whenever we have it uh is
there any other games there was
something that you wanted to oh well in
the beat tournament I'm just checking uh
country kurila was a draw yes I saw that
one against Jacobson was a draw so one
game did we look at that one we can do
it real quick yeah completion here yeah
just quickly sir Brandon oh yes of
course trying the four pounds that's an
Indian uh-huh E6 Bishop E2 Bishop G4
line yeah that's known to be relatively
solid for black
Queen to A5 okay here is where it gets
confusing because I mean you can have
the same position with the inclusion of
A6 A4 or not uh B6 is something new to
me to be perfectly honest Rook E1
King H1 Knight C5 and then why just
captures gives you five looks yeah it
looks looks very promising for white
this one but it turns out the real
Advantage was a little bit
a little bit earlier
so okay still
something is going on something's going
on and how did the draw have it yeah
Bishop Bishop C4 is a sneaky yeah that's
nice that was cool thanks Happy Tree all
right so everyone is happy opposite
colored Bishops
you're not impressed look at all these
great moves okay well so in fact black
was trying right black was trying and he
offered the draw himself
all right well that was a nice little
draw there I don't know four pawns
attack again
uh in fact uh uh that's the thing with
those like old-fashioned very sharp
lines four pounds attack against uh the
ginsengine and also there is one more
for pawns it's four pawns variation
against other kind defense so people
rarely play it but when they do it's
actually a pain to recall I mean what I
was supposed to do once again yeah not
to losing 15 moves
so yeah maybe maybe we'll see more of it
in the future but yeah and over here
what else do we have over here we've
gotten to this position Bishop G4 so
only winning move King C4 was found kc4
was found but then there was another
only winning move Bishop C2 which wasn't
oh wait what he didn't wait
until that he didn't play wait you're
telling me it's a draw yeah it is a draw
after Bishop G4 King E4
and then he goes with this bishop H5
thing but then that's exactly what I was
doing was no understanding that it's
still kind of a border on the way of
this okay without table base yeah you
can even just play F6 right and and
you're just waiting so that the king
cannot enter
is he gonna find this
for odds to figure out how to defense
it doesn't have that many options it'll
be perfectly to be perfectly clear just
have to be sure not to let the black
king get to D3 yeah that's the only big
thing vidit kind of didn't realize that
it didn't realize I mean he was he was a
terrible base so
yeah absolutely no but but yeah that
that was a hard end game insanely hard
with table base we're still sitting here
we're figuring it out and we have all
the tools we need so obviously uh very
difficult could have saved this one yeah
very close to making the draw foreign
we'll see if anything else happens we do
have that interview with Alex Slenderman
ready to go
I'm here with a very very happy Alex
Linderman fresh off his win against
Grandmaster said wani Alex you only need
half a point right now to guarantee you
clear first how are you feeling and how
are you feeling after this uh this
Victory oh very good obviously I mean I
think in my last few games have been you
know
pretty good by my standards so I'm just
happy to be playing I think what I think
is to be a good chess and um really
posing my opponents some problems and
um doing my best every move every game
staying Vigilant and
um yeah so I'm pretty happy
um about that
so could you uh take us through your
game real quick and could you tell all
the people about uh
uh yeah uh sure so let me
scroll up
so
um yeah I decided this game I think
around probably needed to play for a win
because he's one point behind
so I you know I decided to play
something where I have minimal risk
which is why I played Knight C3 okay I
mean there are some kind of drawers
lines but of course I was not afraid of
them because the draw was kind of good
for me this game
um yeah he usually plays Bishop before
but against Bishop before
um you know that's his main repertoire
but there are many
very safe lines against this and I was
going to choose one of them
so he played Knight D7 which I've seen
him he's he's done in the database a few
times
um and then I prepared this idea
Queen C2 it's like a nice flexible move
where I
am not decided if I want to go Bishop 4
or Bishop G5 depends on the situation
um actually what's interesting is that
this position is um my game of last year
against Daniel noraditsky In Reverse
upper Temple like I had this exact
structure with black without you know
the Knight on C3 because I was black so
it's like I'm up a Tempo here so I know
this is should be a good line and I won
that game I played very well so I had
good memories and you know in general I
thought uh you know Raonic is a very
Dynamic player so I was pretty happy
with a structure like this
you know Carl's about structure where I
sort of kill the Dynamics you know
especially given that draw is okay but
then
um you know I start I saw that like I
have this very interesting plan
um to play this rookie one
um
and uh yeah trying to play maybe a four
Knight of 395 and I thought this
actually poses some problems uh so yeah
then I realized that okay we have a
fighting position I actually want to
play for a win here even though draw is
okay it's always important to play
principal chess and
um not play for a draw not play
passively but play the position
um so that's what I was trying to do
now you played Bishop G4 which
completely surprised me
didn't see that move at all I was
expecting something like 96 and stuff
and I was gonna play a fortnight of 395
and
but I guess he's probably
relatively fine but yeah you played this
idea I was a bit surprised
um because I thought I could play a four
trying to trap his Bishop you know with
G4 F5 but then I realized it's not so
simple because I was calculating for a
long time here the move F5
but then he goes Queen D6 and the
problem is G4 goes Queen G3 and he's
winning
um
yeah but um I was planning something
like Knight B1
and then go G4 at some point but the
problem is he goes something like what I
thought Knight D7 okay maybe Knight H7
was better but I mean I thought Knight
somewhere and the problem is of Queen F2
he goes F6 I thought
um and after G4
he goes Queen here
uh Queen here Rook takes E3 and okay it
seemed a bit I actually saw this bishop
C2 but uh I mean maybe this is why he
should go Knight H7 actually because
oh it's it's interesting yeah I mean
this move the queen of two oh Knight G5
yeah yeah anyway I didn't
I thought it's a bit terrific and I saw
this as also an advantage so because I
in two minutes Bishop I realized yeah
this is just very good for white and
queen g2h4 G5 also have an attack
you know so um it's very unpleasant yeah
and then
and then yeah I I'm not sure if I played
the best way but
um
I thought it's very common here he
decided to sack the pawn in order to
activate his Bishop which
sort of makes sense but
like I always thought this is
quite good for me I mean I assume I
didn't play uh perfectly but
but you know I
think I played well enough and here
um yeah I saw that I spotted this G5
idea which I think is quite nice I guess
he kind of missed it he was already a
bit in time pressure because uh here I
you know get the five square
uh which I think is very unpleasant for
him
so
um so yeah uh he played Rook D5
but here I thought it's uh very
difficult maybe he has to go Queen D6
but it's a very unpleasant end game down
opponent
yeah but uh he decided to uh
to try to
take go for the spawn
but uh this I thought is
um
it's winning actually I miss that he can
go Bishop E8 I thought I'm winning
immediately
based on the idea of Bishop D5 Rook G6
and Bishop H5
uh Knight F6 Queen F6 Queen e Queen B8
and then Queen G8 mate
but um but yeah he played Bishop E8 and
yeah it was actually took me a very long
time to try to calculate this because I
I just couldn't see how to break through
because
um
96 page five I thought Queen B8 I
thought he plays like Rook B3
and uh he gets this counter player Rook
G3
Queen E7 or maybe I'm still winning but
I wasn't I didn't see exactly how
So eventually I realized that there's
some problems with my king so I've after
spending like almost all my time
I know 40 I played this H5 idea which is
probably clean because
again Bishop H5 does not work because of
Knight F6
and then I want to go King H4 and then
Knight D6 and I secure the G6 Square
because the point is if I go Knight D6
immediately it goes Bishop page five so
I wanted to take that square away so I
was pretty happy with finding this idea
and now
yeah he you know he played uh yeah
basically the idea is after Rook A3 I go
Knight D6
um so he yeah he played C5 and the way
the game ended was 96.
Bishop D7 knight uh Rook G6
um Eric B1
Rook text H6
and now with King G7 it's important like
go Queen G3 takes Queen G6 which is
quite nice
and they have King G8
um I it there is one last trap don't go
Queen G4 because here if I go Rook G4
there's suddenly Rook H1 where am I
maybe I'm still winning but okay maybe
not maybe not so Queen G3 last precision
and here he resigned because after Queen
G7 I go Rook G6 Rook H1 King G4 and
unfortunately for him after takes I
could take what the H Pawn still so he's
gonna lose the queen and
and he loses the game so yeah in general
I was pretty happy about with this game
I mean obviously I didn't play perfectly
it was a complex game but I think for my
standards on I'm quite happy with with
the game
uh and in general you know with my last
few games
oh that's lovely
and uh tomorrow you're gonna be
red block well I feel good because uh
there is uh very little pressure uh
because I'm guaranteed the tie for first
and obviously I'll just try to play a
normal game but I mean even worse comes
to worse if I were to lose I feel like I
still have a you know white game and the
end where I can you know try to get a
draw but obviously yeah tomorrow you
know just don't think too much about
result just play a good game just try to
continue what I've been doing and
whatever happens happens
um
it's whatever happens happens to keep in
a level head that's a very good way to
do it and uh we hope to see you back in
the studio soon good luck in your last
round thank you so much all right that
was Grandmaster Alex Lenderman in a very
comfortable spot two points ahead two
rounds to go and a very healthy attitude
about it so uh this is one where we just
might see maybe tomorrow we'll already
be able to declare a winner of the B
group
all right I can see you have your all of
your eyes all of your attention here on
the Hans game yeah well not much uh
currently goes on in the conscious okay
so he
he being Hans he prefer to keep the pawn
on F5 which probably is even more secure
because it's you know it's a little
fence on the way of uh uh blocking it
cannot really yeah so basically in order
to win you either need the king here or
somehow
being able to swing around and get the
king to G4 right right and that both
seem to be like really unrealistic like
with the King on C4 white uh well sticks
to the policy of doing nothing there's
shuffling the bishop here and there and
yeah and it takes white only say one
check when you've done all the job and
went to H6 it's one check and then go
back and one more time just for anybody
that maybe is just joining or whatever
where was the exact moment that black
went wrong yeah I wish
we have table base so it'll be yeah yeah
yeah it'll tell us the exact moment
actually yeah okay where black went
wrong we actually do know the
interesting thing is that could it be
that white was never lost I mean would
he play it precisely because yeah it
seems that this moment where black was
winning yeah it is clear-cut absolutely
so once again King D5 King C4 King E3
and that was the moment to attack the
pawn from C2
not only attacking the pawn but also
covering E4 Square
and a white actually needs to decide
does he wants to keep a point does he
want to keep a pawn because you lose the
pawn it's fairly trivial I believe yeah
or you go here and then the king gets to
the tree and then you can actually do
exactly what vidi did right like stop
the pawn with the bishop and so on oh
boy
uh right can we go all the way back
let's go far far back we obviously we
have plenty of time I think they're
going to play this one out I'm assuming
it's I mean it's very unlikely that it
won't be a draw now but maybe this game
will go on forever who knows
um all the way to the moment where Huns
even allowed this like double he was
down two puns at like some moment
uh right so we could go all the way all
the way back here because it's also in a
way to get the Rooks yes also yeah in a
way it's a very interesting kind of
point right after Bishop E4 you do have
other moves yes you could try Rook D7
for instance if black takes your Pawn
you take black spawn so he keeps you
keep the Rooks on the board and usually
kind of consensus between the chess
players is that if you're not sure that
you're holding right with the bishop you
keep the Rooks right okay very true well
technically it adds more possibilities
for the kind of strongest side but I
mean if right yeah like also maybe one
day this Rook generates gone to play
Everything puts so much pressure he had
no doubt whatsoever he just went through
d8 yeah Black Blade B5 which as we
figured out was Black's only shot at
playing for win so B5 was actually very
clever now white is limited to only
moves because yeah this then you somehow
have to stop this Pawn so once again
Bishop A5 or E7 I don't think it's it's
all that much different so this one we
are getting by force H5
and here the engine still kind of
indecisive okay G3 Bishop C2 so it was
uh look after H5 it's 0 9. I'm talking
about my engine here at this computer
which is not very deep once again people
at home yeah it doesn't analyze it much
better but uh I just wanted illustrate
how confused the engine is because this
moment it says H5 after H5 the
evaluation is minus 0.9 so for example
Pawn it's all Advantage yeah it suggests
King G3 we play King G3 and the engine
says okay I changed my mind it's minus
3.5
how do you how do you actually what do
you make out of it yeah so just a very
important lesson for people analyzing
games with you know engines that there
are these kinds of positions where
there's going to be these swings and you
kind of have to know how to use an
engine a lot more in order to understand
like what's actually going on because
sometimes computer's not going to tell
you this yeah well especially like
closer to the end of the game with all
those end games like computer might be
claiming hey this site's winning and
it's a huge plus but it's only because
in some I don't know 15 moves long line
you have this only study like move which
wins and all the rest will be a dead
draw like for instance here vidit found
the right plan he found a sequence of
maybe five six only moves and then one
move in the wrong direction and it's
gone and absolutely and that's kind of
what happened it was it was a situation
where as soon as Vinnie maybe had a win
a table base
maybe not miraculous win but very
difficult win to find uh I guess did go
wrong for him he yep and then I mean
this was all brilliant too by the
bringing the king this way first and
then running back around the other way
hmm
so here he's not uh-huh
Bishop B2 it was saying -5 so like black
is winning
and then black is no longer winning
nice the position of the king G3 Bishop
C2
stock which is ensure a depth around so
people are in depth of 100 at home I
mean it
figured out 100 is no joke that's crazy
but yeah basically this under this kind
of you have to understand that asking
even from such a good players
uh to play this end game without utmost
Precision it's yeah it's unrealistic
it's unrealistic
so yeah so far so good uh Bishop A3
was this a mistake now that I'm thinking
could it be that like Bishop B2 I'm
Still Still The King goes yeah so it's
probably not that different from
H5 yeah and here clearly black was yeah
black here was actually according to
machine uh Bishop D1 was not needed you
do not really need to force this spawn
so maybe it was easier to say go King B5
first and then King C4 you probably end
up in this kind of same same position
yeah but anyway
so you went here and this is where we
enter table based territory King D5 is
still fine Bishop tanks King to C4
that's a win okay King E3
and the only winning move was Bishop C2
yeah
from C2 attacking the pawn right away
but the big idea
is that the king kind of the white king
is going to need to move at some point
yeah the black king gets in it's a win
for black yeah and we could also got a
highlight
uh let's say
white pretense he does exactly the same
as in the game but yeah but with no
other button without a an F Pawn but
yeah but then this Pawn starts moving
and it gets to each tree and it will
have to stop it right
uh let me just that's I don't know yeah
Bishop moves H5 here H4 and at some
point you actually have to run after
this pawn and black goes and takes the
bishop and you don't have the pawn to
distract black right and luckily for
black the remain yeah the remaining
looking at the corner the remaining Rook
pawn and the Bishop
Square yeah that you were trying to
promote on white would have a draw the
bishop of the right color
so here we are
Keen to have four and it's been here for
quite a while
last capture was moved 63 now we are at
move 87 now it's not it's not only about
captures the pawn moves as well
okay we did of course we'll play it for
bajillion more moves perfect looking for
ways to we're seeing plenty of time to
go get some popcorn come back and uh
yeah sit around let's just let's just
quickly check what the B tournament what
happens in the B tournament yeah yes we
still had one less than a minute as just
I was pointing out we had less than a
minute one game going that's still black
night up harutinyan was Black Knight top
for the born but yeah but somehow still
struggles
still struggles
this guy how long do they have
just just other other curios it is so
this material we we actually have for
quite some yeah this is almost exactly
there was on move 40 so when they passed
the time control black was up at night
and somehow I don't know if he played
like the most precise moves but yeah
let's leave it aside for now
um
yeah you'd expect this one to be maybe
if not easily but relatively easily
winning
and he struggles he clearly struggles
okay he tried to try to kind of go in
with the King it didn't work
then yeah it's a move 62 we are talking
about we are nowhere near this 50 moves
rule because also the pawn was moved and
so on but yeah but it's not not obvious
how black is going to make progress oh
boy
yes Knight G5 I I reckon Rook f8 yeah
rook f8 and then the pawn is guarded and
yeah one way of winning this would be
would be to try to force the Rooks no
but you you can't really you know I
thought like get the Rook to the f file
but then white will be guarding this
Pawn from A3 no matter which way you go
I'm in a garden yeah yeah so that's
that's not not that easy not that easy
at all we still are you are you
confident that black is winning this or
is it not at all not at all
uh for what I know like winning with the
bishop sometimes is even easier yeah
it's easy uh
uh most of the cases but even with the
bishop sometimes we should versus this
Pawn like you have HG and the bishop an
opponent has F G H and uh yeah we both
have Rooks it might be not not trivial
it might be not trivial these are always
hard yeah so that's what we have I went
now G5 Rook uh f8 so now all right maybe
maybe try to get the kind of Swing the
king all the way back with the third
piece then you yeah then you win that
that's how you prove you actually have
an extra piece right at night to uh
sorry King to E7 was a suggestion but
then yeah but then he goes back to F5
it's once again it's really hard to kind
of get rid of this stupid drug yeah
listen
yeah it feels like some of the king
would need to be attacking the f-pawn
but he's trying it hey yeah that sort of
tries something can you six okay he
forgets
true against uh maybe swing the Knight
to D4 ah okay so let's say if white
patiently waiting then this is the
position that he wants to get and this
one is winning because Rook f492 check
yeah okay okay yeah at least we gotta
get something to work with yeah it could
be okay
okay so that's one chance idea a very
good job that's one sit down pm
but obviously white can try to yeah try
to
to do something about this
thank you okay back to Hans back to Hans
[Music]
um
is very active on G5 but since the pawn
since the pawn black pawn that is past
this diagonal there is no chance of
winning whatsoever because you wait with
the Bish and you wait like literally you
go Bishop A1 B2 A1 B2 this looks like a
much clearer way for uh white to hold
this and yeah I mean you don't actually
have to react to anything when the king
is on C2 right and you can even still
wait you can wait for black to push B2
take it and only then go F7 yeah which
is sensible so basically yeah the point
is like what the king is far enough you
go F7 yeah that's what he does it now
yeah King is far enough of the king E4
says Hans Neiman sir whatever King E4
was played F7 Bishop F7 King H3 it will
be seven in a row
would you call this one solid
yeah the draw is it wrong yeah yeah at
the end of the day seven draws in a row
yeah black is a piece of move
103 all right and the round finally
wrong
move draw hands in a way very lucky to
get it and with that we're going to be
wrapping up our coverage of today by
looking at these standings now in the a
group let's see how things have shaken
up
is the sole leader both groups with a
sole leader this one only by half a
point because Von Nguyen also won today
and is sitting at four and a half points
right under that still with a shot is
vidit and Gregory o'parin they both have
four points Hans Neiman now uh a perfect
three and a half out of seven perfect
score perfect drawers consistent score
of three and a half so does ilyonese
Nick and nijot amsoff uh as well as
Aaron Jacobian and then there's Nicholas
theodoro in Syria Ganguly at the bottom
of the pairings Mira what is going on in
Group B uh Group B well we still have
one game pending but that's in a kind of
a lower
lower part of the Cross table so it's a
huge tie for the second we don't know
who's going to be the second in this
tournament correct it's 99 sure we know
who is the who is the winner Alex
landabonnet absolutely stunning
performance in last rounds so six out of
seven I wish I could score something
like that oh my gosh yeah and then run
next advani Christopher you will lead us
a couple of days ago yes kept losing and
they are called by gergely contour and
Dennis countries
need to wait until tomorrow to see if we
have an official winner of the B group
group we will know potentially tomorrow
and other than that it's been an
excellent show a longer show yeah a
longer show but as well an exciting one
and I'm so glad thank you to everybody
that has been watching we will join you
tomorrow for round eight
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited